hey everybody welcome to the live coding
with Jesse I'm Jesse and today we're
gonna make a react component component
from start to finish we're gonna pull in
data from my sequel database using graph
QL and Apollo and then we're gonna use
that data to put into the components and
render multiple components so this is
probably gonna be a short stream so this
is something that I've done many times I
don't anticipate making a lot of
mistakes but if you've watched the
stream before you know I do often make
mistakes so it could happen so before we
get started I just want to bring you up
to date on how I fixed or how I and
Michael
Creole fixed an issue that we had I
believe on the last stream so and it's
heading true so I'm not a hundred
percent sure that I don't know that we
had the issue on the last stream or not
now that I think about it but anyway we
we were trying to get the faculty list
pages to work and we had made a new
component and we made a new query but
it's just I found that when I was trying
to get categories that had more than one
word then they were hyphenated it
wouldn't work it turns out I was
searching for the name which would be
the title and WordPress instead of the
slug and the name of course when it has
more than one word has commas sometimes
and spaces and all sorts of things so
that's what my problem was
and I
worked on it for a long time on my own
couldn't figure it out I made a get up
issue for it and Michael saw it and
realized what was going on and submitted
a pull request that pretty much sorted
everything out I still needed to make a
few adjustments in my router because I
had actually made another mistake in the
routing function that I didn't even
realize because it was kind of buried
under this this other mistake so I had
to adjust that and I adjusted some
things in the component as well to deal
with some errors that came up after that
so there were just layers upon layers of
my mistakes that I had to get through so
that's all sorted out now so those pages
do work I just don't have all the routes
in yet so I did open up an issue for
adding the routes if anyone would like
to do that it's it's actually pretty
boring work so I'm going to do it at
some point I just made the issue one to
remind me to do it and then to if
anybody really wanted to eat a pull
request for doing some like tedious work
then feel free to take that one okay I
think that's all my updates I don't know
something I for some reason I think
there's something else I wanted to share
but I can't remember it now so I guess
we'll just get started let me make sure
the stream all right stream health looks
good let me know if anything's going on
so I am streaming some from home today
so you know sometimes the the Health's
not that good but I think it'll work out
so I'm gonna start my timer on my other
screen so a Pomodoro session we're gonna
try to do a 25-minute session of coding
and then I'll take a break and do some
some questions we may not need two full
sessions today let's see let me switch
my screen oops
area
okay so probably can't see much because
it's really small I'll make it a bit
bigger for you and what you see on the
screen and stuff I was working on
previously so we're gonna run a switch
out of there so I mean basically I was
working on routes cleaning update on the
WordPress side of things so nothing
super interesting I did go through the
analytics from the current site to
figure out what pages are viewed most
and so I'm gonna focus my efforts on
those pages before launch I'm gonna get
the data for all the pages but in terms
of how the pages look and the most the
pages that get the most testing I'm
gonna stick with maybe the top 20 pages
in terms of views really the the top two
pages get all the views and then every
page after that gets like 1% or less of
all the views so it's not it's it's it's
kind of hard to say like hey here's the
top 20 pages because the difference in
views between like number 20 and number
like 100 or like 10th of a percent so
it's not not really a huge huge
difference but let me show you what page
what pages we're gonna be working on
what component we're gonna make first so
you get the visual then we'll go to the
code hey everyone I see a lot of you
saying hi now on the end the chat so hey
Michael's here Michael thank you I don't
know if you caught the beginning where I
explained how you saved me from my
mistake there with our graph QL queries
but I really appreciate that so thank
you so let's go to localhost first and
actually let's see let's go to that fine
arts faculty because that's the one that
was giving me the most trouble or at
least that was wherever oh yeah I it's
taking long because of the stream I was
really worried for a second but okay
here we are
so here's our page for fine arts faculty
and I'm gonna go to that same page on
the current main website just to give
you an idea of what people see now
because their expectations if they've
seen one of these pages before are gonna
be based on what they're seeing now so
I'm not gonna recreate it pixel for
pixel but we should at least try to have
the same basic data so we're gonna go to
Franciscan DB use whoops arts and
faculty so we'll go there and you can go
to that site as well if you'd like we
also have a we have a test you know what
I haven't updated the test site I'm not
gonna try update it now cuz it'll take
forever while I'm streaming but I'll be
sure to try and update that that demo
site I believe it's I forget the URL
I'll probably I'll let you know the URL
when I do the next stream so y'all can
check out the site as well but no sense
right now because all of this stuff that
we've done in the past week isn't
available anyway all right so here's how
it looks so there's there's this huge I
guess you could say kind of hero section
that are on these pages which we're not
gonna try to replicate that right now
these pages to be honest with you are
rarely visited in terms of the total
site visits so they're not a priority
right now and we'd like to have input
from each of the departments before we
go in and start redoing things but
basically with what they have now is an
image the name and then title and a link
so right now getting the image is going
to be if we're gonna get the image now
based on the data that we have we're
gonna have to maybe use maybe a regular
expression or something to search out
the URL to the image because we don't
that you're gonna kind of nicely
available in its own field so we can
grab that but that's gonna be you know
if we have time let's grab that because
it'll be a little bit more difficult
what we really need is the name which we
already have we just need to make it
look nice and we need this this link
which we can get easily the title is
also gonna be a little bit different but
if we can look in the mark-up and see
that like hey all the titles are let's
say in a certain type of tag or they all
have a certain class we may be able to
just grab these as well maybe with a
regular expression we'll see so we may
be able to display these properly with
all the data we want without having to
go back and manually edit the the data
that we currently have so if you haven't
followed along for a lot of the project
we're stuck with a lot of data and
markup as is from migrating the data
from a previous content management
system so that's why I'm trying to do
these little workarounds to to be able
to work with data that's not in an ideal
format at some point I'd love to be able
to change the data but we don't have
enough time before the site is gonna
launch on June 4th
ok so I'm thinkin - in terms of design
there's two options that I think we can
take one is to do cards and have kind of
a masonry layout with the cards for the
professors the other layout would be
just to keep kind of like we have here
this list format and to keep some sort
of list format so let me know in the
live chat what you think just to give
you an idea of what the card could look
like let's so let's go to the main page
in a new tab here and when that does
load you'll be able to see
you know potentially what what it could
look like while that's loading I do want
to remind everyone in case or if you
haven't heard yet
a few of the viewers that I believer
here in the live chat today at least I
saw Nikki so Nikki and Harshit and
JavaScript ER who's occasionally in the
live chat and i/o created a site for
people to be able to share their github
repositories and find cool JavaScript
repositories that are not really
well-known but are kind of worth knowing
and that site is called JavaScript AF so
whoops I'll paste that in the live chat
right now so if you'd like to check that
out you know please feel free to check
it out so oops I didn't get the link
it's just it's not a clickable link but
if you just copy and paste JavaScript AF
in the browser you'll you know you'll
get in and see this after you log in
with your github profile we're not
trying to take your data but to use the
functionality and actually add repos you
do have to be logged in so we may make
it so that you don't have to be logged
in I open an issue for that so you'd
only have to be logged in for certain
things but you could still see things
without being logged in for now you do
need to log in at first though but
basically you can see you know we have
some repos if you were to click let's
just click on this the latest one that
was added you can see the readme and
some statistics so you'll have the
ability later on in beta when we add
more features to upload repositories so
there will be different searching
options so it should be I'm hoping what
it'll be is an easier way to search the
github repos and leh I said just a way
to find really cool stuff out there that
maybe is kind of getting lost underneath
all of the the bigger repositories that
get most of the attention so please
check it out and let me know your
opinion okay so this is an example of
how a profile could look actually
looking at this now it reminds me that I
believe this image is too big I need to
make some restrictions on on images for
the cards it just is it's taking up a
huge portion of the screen there but
anyway it would be something like the
faculty profile card name title and then
a length so our option is to do
something like this or to do something
that would be more of a list style more
horizontally oriented so as I said let
me know in the live chat if you have a
preference I guess I'm gonna make a
decision on this here in about 30
seconds I will give you a bit of a time
for the delay to go through to see if
you have any any opinion on that I'm
just scanning through the chat to see if
anyone as an opinion looks like not yet
so about in about 15 more minutes I'm
gonna answer questions in the chat so if
you're asking questions just please be
patient with me okay cool so Sasha says
card style Michael Kors style Sasha
forgive me if I'm wrong about this but I
don't remember seeing you in the chat
before so welcome if I have seen you and
I just don't remember
you know apologies for that but anyway
welcome to the chat and thank you for
letting me know which style you perfor
prefer it looks like the card alright
great so everybody likes the card this
is actually gonna make our job easier
because we can probably borrow a lot of
the mark-up from the current car
component so let's let's see where we
have that so we're gonna go into our
code here all this code is available and
it's open source the repository link is
in the description to this video feel
free to check out that code use it for
whatever new edition of the code just
today was a code of conduct so no so far
nobody has done anything remotely in
violation of the code of conduct but if
you're gonna say something or do
something that you're not sure whether
or not you should do just check out the
code of conduct beforehand but it's nice
to have one of those hopefully we never
have to actually enforce it and so for
everybody in this community has just
been very pleasant certainly to me and
and also with each other as far as I
know well those are the pages I need to
look for components okay where is our
components profile card so let's check
out our profile card component and we'll
see
so yes for now let's just copy this and
I mean honestly we'll see I'm gonna make
a new component now but it's gonna end
up being pretty close to what we already
have this one needs to be a little bit
more versatile I think because you're
using it for multiple types of profiles
but I don't know if I really want to
just change this one to work in our use
case yeah I mean to me I there's a
balance between making component
reusable for a lot of different
situations and making a component
bloated with all these different options
so I don't know I kind of think this
component is maybe like on the border of
that right now so let's just go ahead
and make another component you know at
least it'll be good for educational
purposes to make a new component and go
from there so let's call this faculty
lists item okay so that's what it is
right now pretty specific so like I said
maybe this this may end up changing a
lot or gettin combined with another
component or we may end up taking this
component and making a little bit more
general so that we can use it in other
situations oops
I named this improperly I meant to do a
a capital so usually components
are capitalized and then at the first
part in the camel case so not it not
always but that you seems to usually be
the the way components are named so I'm
I'm running Spotify on my phone and I
went to press the skip the song key on
my keyboard and it wasn't working
like what its Abney because it's on my
phone okay so here's what we have let's
scoot this over will scoot this down a
bit just want to give us as much room as
possible and okay it looks like let me
go through this a little bit and just
we'll see what the component is so I
know I title this creating a component
so you know potentially you might be
expecting to do this from scratch but to
be entirely honest with you I never make
a component from scratch and if you're
trying to make a components from scratch
other than for educational purposes then
my personal opinion is that you you are
wasting I don't wanna say wasting but
you're taking more time to create it
then you need to write because it's it
wouldn't be a waste you probably learn
things when you do it but in reality the
structure of components is there's
usually a base structure that can be
reused and you can always find a
component that's similar enough to what
you want to do that you have a starting
place so this is actually how I do
create new components I always start
with some component that I've previously
made so what this gives us is a lot that
we would need for most components anyway
so we're bringing in things from react
right we're bringing in our styles from
material UI which is the
material design framework that we're
using we're bringing in components from
material UI that we can build on
all right we're bringing in typography
which gives us automatically styles for
our text for font and we're bringing in
a button right so these are basic things
that we should not be recreating over
and over again if we want to be able to
develop things with with any speed at
all so having said that we also bring in
some styles right so these styles are
gonna be useful to us now we may not
need to keep them all so we may take out
some things that we don't need from this
component so if you notice we you know
we have this I'm trying to see this same
component is used for multiple things so
we don't really need to say what type of
profile this is because on the page
where we're gonna use this on there's
not gonna be multiple profile types so
we're gonna be able to take this section
out we're also let's let's go through it
I believe there's some other stuff we
can take out but we'll see well once we
get there so this category section right
here we can take this out because we
won't be using that and we will take the
corresponding prop for that which would
be profile type so that's not going to
be an available prop we're gonna take it
already use it here this profile type
here
right so we've removed all that you
notice I have this commented out I'm
going to keep this in here just to test
it and see whether this gives us better
dimensions for our images if it does not
I'm gonna delete it so we're not
planning on keeping that the what we had
before and by default and material UI
with cards media that you have in cards
so mostly images at the top of the cars
were background images put in with CSS
but we ran into some issues with that
when I was testing with with my intern
and some things that he had noticed and
brought to my attention so we tested out
using just a regular image tag instead
and that gave us better results but I
want to make sure that those are
actually better results in a variety of
use cases so that's why I haven't
completely gotten rid of this yet all
right so just a quick scan through here
I'll explain what this is doing and
we'll see if we can remove anything else
where we have some of the props that
were passing in which are our profile
image so this would be the URL to the
image this is the image title for the
the title attribute on our image we have
our profile name which would be the name
of the person and then we'll have
content and a profile link so the
content is going to be the the quote
portion so in our case the the content
is just going to be the title of the
person instead of an actual quote from
that person so we may rename this to
make it you know more obvious but for
now just when we're testing it it's it's
okay and then we have a link with a just
a basic button style and that's it it's
gonna be
simple component so let's test it out
let me make sure I've saved it and we
need to test this out now in our faculty
list so we need to bring in this
component so we need to import it so we
can use it so I'm just gonna copy and
paste this other component that we
brought in from the same folder that'll
be easy to change and we've called our
component faculty list item so now we'll
be able to use that and if we go down
here and our faculty list J which is
just through this n2 and h3 so we don't
we don't want to leave it like that
that's not really visually appealing so
now we're gonna replace this with our
faculty lists we call it again item so
our faculty list item and we're gonna
need to put in a bunch of props but
we're not gonna just just put in the
props by hand in this this case we're
going to put in variables right there as
we're mapping through this we're gonna
grab that data from the graph QL the
things that we're bringing in so let's
see we need let's let's check here to
see what we need to pull in and we don't
need to pull all of these in some of
these will be optional so for now what
we're not pulling in is an image or a
title so we're just gonna pull in what
we have for now just to see what it
looks like on the page so we're gonna
pull in
this for profile name we're gonna have
whoops not the profile name is going to
equal faculty node title and then we're
also going to have our profile link and
this one's gonna be a little bit more
tricky so right now our profile link is
like a full URL what we want it to be is
let me see let's that I break it I think
I did oh yeah cuz I'm working on this
page right now so we need sorry wrong
page I need to find out what the lit URL
is to go to this page this link not work
I guess who it only works no it doesn't
work at all
that's weird
oh maybe it's just so slow okay so
faculty and then that's how it works all
right so I just wanted to know how I had
the throw out setup so it's gonna be so
let's do it like this
so in react when we put these brackets
in that means we can write JavaScript in
here so we're writing JavaScript and we
want to put in a template literal so
we're gonna do a template literal and
it's gonna be slash faculty slash and
then here's where the variables gonna
come in so we're gonna put a dollar sign
and then a curly bracket which lets us
put in a variable so right here is a
string this is the variable and the
variable is gonna be faculty node slug
which I believe I'm bringing that in
we'll find out in a second if I actually
am so our link is always gonna be to a
faculty page and then that slug is gonna
tell us what faculty page to get to pull
in right and we've already set all this
up in previous streams the only thing we
need to be careful of is making sure in
the data that we have that's in my
sequel database making sure that all the
slugs are actually correct which since
we're pulling the data in with the slugs
and then we're taking that same slug and
using it to grab the data again we
should be fine so even if the slug
itself is in a weird format that we
don't like it still should work so now I
can get rid of
oops you know what let's bring over this
key let's make sure I don't already have
a key on here I don't
okay
actually you know this is this isn't
gonna look great and I'll tell you why
in a minute after we see that it's not
gonna look great um but we'll add some
more into here to make this look nicer
so let me say that hopefully hopefully I
did this right and I'm still getting
this what was this faculty list item
quote oops
I believe I messed something up when I
took out these Stiles yep
I did I forgot a comma all right
hopefully that was it
oh and my timer ran out and I didn't
even realize it so let me go I'm gonna
take a five-minute break I'm gonna go to
the chat and answer your questions and
then we'll come back and see if if this
will work how it looks what else we need
to do Stephen says can you talk about
what graph QL does just a short
description sure no problem
so graph QL why should say for those of
you who are familiar with rest api's
think of graph QL as just another way to
access data that is very similar to a
REST API but imagine if you could tell
the API exactly what you wanted instead
of being restricted to the pre-built API
routes for those of you who have no idea
what API is at all it's just graph QL is
just a way for us to send a message to a
server and ask for certain pieces of
information and then that information
gets sent back to us okay so in this
case we have our react application is
asking for data using the graph QL
format right it's just a certain way to
ask all right it's a way to format the
question so that we get the answer that
we
and then our database is connected to a
wordpress installation we have a plug-in
called WP graph QL and that plug-in is
able to recognize when we ask a question
using graph QL and then answer properly
with the correct data once we get that
answer then we can display it on a page
using our react components so that is
what all graph QL is the reason graph QL
is better than a normal REST API is
because going back to a really basic
thing and a normal API there's only a
preset list of answers that it will give
and questions that you can ask but with
graph QL you can ask any questions that
you want and assuming that that data
actually exists you will get all the
data back right the way you want I guess
I'll give it a real-world example like
imagine if imagine if you called the
grocery store to see if they had some
certain items in stock and with the REST
API there would be you called and
there's one of those automated things
and it says press one to find out how
many apples we have press two to find
out how many oranges we have right you
could there was no option to
automatically say I want to find apples
and oranges you'd have to actually call
back again and then press press one for
apples hang up call back again press two
for oranges with a graph QL API you
could just get on the phone and say hey
I want to know how many apples and
oranges there are and then it would give
you the apples and oranges right then
you wouldn't have to make two phone
calls okay that's why graph QL is better
hopefully as a decent explanation let me
know let me know if it was confusing
the component are just regular
JavaScript other things are specific to
react so to try to give you like this
function here this get initial props is
specific to next J s which is a way to
build with react but down here where
we're doing this dot map and we're
mapping over this is just regular
JavaScript this is dot map and then
we're using an arrow function within
here okay but then once we jump back in
inside of the arrow function we're back
in react land where we're using this
component okay but then you know inside
here we have template literal syntax
which is just es6 javascript so a react
component is a very integrated mix of
regular javascript stuff and then some
stuff that is unique to react or unique
to a particular package that you're
using with react in our case next jazz
oh cool in Sasha says that this was
first time in here so awesome
so yeah alright so officially now
without doubt welcome and thank you for
for letting me know which which option
look better there so let's see Oh John
Hanson says still having errors to try
to get the repo for JavaScript AF to
work properly
alright John if you haven't already done
this open up an issue in the github
repos for those projects and let us know
what errors you're getting if you some
copy and paste the error in there then
harsh it's probably gonna be the one
that's gonna be able to help you the
most since he did a lot of the work for
this but if I can figure out what's
going on from the errors and help you I
will I will definitely do so and I'd
like to have it in an issue and then
that way if someone else has a similar
issue later on then they can also a
benefit from it as well okay so my timer
my five-minute timer went off so I'm
gonna go back and check on this
component and depending on if it works
or not I may go right back to questions
or we may work on this a bit more
alright let me wait a second
why am I getting there on that page that
was weird
all right okay so we have something now
it doesn't look like it's supposed to
look and if you haven't already figured
out I'll tell you why in a second but
what we do have is a much nicer padding
already we have some indication that
these are separate we have our buttons
with is the link properly going in there
or not I'm not seeing it but let's
let's see if there's actually a link in
here since I don't see it
now I don't see a link what did I do
wrong let's to check out our component
it's possible I omitted something
important maybe
you just double-check what's going on
that that it looks like it's supposed to
so there should be well let me try to
click it let's click it and see what
happens okay it does work I assume that
the link tag we were using would result
in an a tag in the markup hey wow that
so uh I I know I explained that this
should work but I was so surprised that
it actually worked that the length work
worked and there's a lot of information
there the format is decent definitely
not ideal but decent wonderful alright
so we're gonna go back at least we know
that the links are working so I'm gonna
go back and probably maybe the last
thing I do
we'll see did I accidentally click this
again I think I did okay just stop all
right I'll get these in more of a
masonry look so let's go to our home
page where we already have a masonry
layout working maybe homes kind of
cluttered you know what let's go to our
search page because that also has a
masonry layout but it's not nearly as
cluttered okay so is this it do we have
a masonry layout on search or not now I
can't even remember it's been so long
since we worked on this so this would be
a search or so class
you know what I don't think we do
all right so let's go to our home page
I'm not sure if I have it up already so
I'm gonna open up our little sidebar
here and go down to pages index close
that give us some space okay so what
we're gonna need right off the bat is a
grid container and let's go with
all right so let's go with the container
I'm just gonna copy this and then we'll
close the tags after we copy it over but
some of this whoops
you know I don't I don't want to all
this right away I want these two first
because these are gonna go outside of
here so these will actually replace this
div and then so we just need masonry we
are gonna need to import mason so let's
let's do that before we forget because
this will get an error if we don't
import it so we'll bring in masonry and
then we also need to bring in grid which
I don't think we have yet yep not yet
masonry and grid
okay so now we can go whoops it's good
the right place here and let's just pull
in a grid that we're already using we're
also gonna need to bring in these
classes cuz we'll get an error from that
as well if we don't fix that well just
did I not get the whole thing nope I
didn't that's copy and paste the whole
thing so we're gonna copy that and then
paste in this whole grid element so if
you're not familiar with with material
UI you probably at least recognized by
the name of grid what this is doing this
this is gonna lay things out in a
certain way certain screen width okay so
here's our grid and let me save you get
some formatting in here should format
for me so right now we have it set on
extra small screens to take up the full
width of the screen which is fine and
then on small screens to take up half
the screen medium to take up half the
screen large to take up half the screen
we've had my at least based on what OBS
is telling me telling me my stream
dropped off for a second so if it did I
apologize
hopefully it's good now okay yeah well
we need the the styles so we may want to
adjust this and we need that grid and
read our Styles here
[Music]
so you see here this looks like a
JavaScript object with CSS in it and
that's pretty much exactly what it is
it's a way to write CSS using javascript
and have it live right in your component
this really helps a lot with reusability
but it is a little bit weird to get used
to it first so hopefully this will work
without me bringing in anything else I
think it will but we can double check
the Styles nope I believe I need will
see if I get in here I think I need
classes is not defined
I think I do need with styles then
which Styles let's see what we have down
here
those with route with data and then we
also need with styles styles hopefully
that'll work it should work since we're
reusing compose or let's check
ah no okay where is this at faculty list
is 41
oops I know I we never brought in
that
so we did pass in we passed in classes
here so we're not gonna be able to do
this in the same way but for instance
let's see where's my other component
here
faculty list item so we're doing
something similar so you can see we have
this inside of our render we can do cons
classes so we'll put it in here
we weren't passing any other props in
like that so this is called
destructuring when we do it like that so
basically allows us to omit this dot
props before each one of our props so
really helps to save a lot of typing and
a lot of space in your component if you
have a lot of props like we do here
we're gonna do it here as well although
in this case not not really that much
going on but there could be and most
likely will be so we're gonna anticipate
that so we're gonna say closed classes
and equals this props let's say that
that should fix our issue
and I just keep manually refreshing
because the auto refresh takes forever
when I'm streaming but normally you you
wouldn't like if you're gonna work on
this project locally you you would not
need to manually refresh if your
computer is at all capable that way why
did it not work hmmm
all right what did I do wrong
all right let's compare our use of
classes here so pretty much the same
okay let's make sure I copied this end
properly so we have constant styles
equal steam arrow
everything looks fine there let's see
let me make sure what I did bring in
yeah it should be fine like this oh let
me let me check the live chat and see if
you all see something I'm missing
all right I don't see anything all right
let me I'm just gonna check my imports
again to make sure I was doing this oh
that's interesting
so not sure if this will have an impact
at all but I'm definitely using a
different way to import that it it
shouldn't make a difference but I'd
rather do what we're doing here because
these are both now actually it's not
this isn't a regular component this is a
page component so I will try it the only
other thing I can think of is what we're
doing down the bottom within composed
maybe is it's not working
for those of you joining me for the
first time I do mess up in this dream
quite frequently and because this is
supposed to be my normal everyday work
and I do make mistakes every day so I
don't practice this beforehand and I
think part of the value of the stream is
that I make mistakes and and we work
through it together and try to come to
the solution and I think that's a more
realistic view of what web development
is then if I were to pre you know
rehearse all this and do it perfectly
alright Stiles
okay so I wonder if let's look at this
page and see what we're doing here
I guess we're not we don't have any
styles on this page there's got to be a
page where we're both using styles in
our component and we are bringing in
data so let me think where would we be
doing
let's check the search page so I think
that's probably where we would be all
right so do we do have styles and maybe
we're bringing in data now I think about
it we're not using graph QL on this page
so we curl the arm yeah that's not gonna
work all right let's check out our major
page yes yes this is Stiles
all right excellent
with her there we go so this is probably
the problem I was just doing this wrong
down here there is some different one on
up top as well so we may need to change
two things
so let's correct this and we're gonna
add and we should just be able to add
this I believe that's that's what we
want to be doing let's check it now yeah
it works cool alright so this is more of
what we were going for you can see we
have what's called a masonry layout
[Music]
let's try to drop down so we can see so
you see once we drop down to a certain
place it automatically changes come as a
nice like switching effect and cool
alright so that works like I said before
I may not want on a large screen to have
let's let's get rid of this for a second
if my leg will allow it all right it
won't but you can imagine on a larger
screen may be too big you know consider
once we do put an image in you know if
that's the width of the image and it's a
tall image it's gonna be huge right we
don't really want that so we may limit
the size of the card but
so far I mean it's still very plain but
our links work it looks a lot nicer than
it did when we started and I'm not gonna
mess around with trying to pull data out
of our our content right now I'll just
maybe if I have some time I gotta save
my kids to soccer practice today so I
may not have time today but if I
remember maybe I'll make some issues and
if any of you all are interested in
pulling out the proper data you can take
a shot at it as well I think that's
that's not bad for right now all right
so I am going to scroll up to where I
left off and answer the rest of these
questions
I didn't stream yesterday because I was
at the Google i/o extension conference
in Pittsburgh which ended up being
really awesome if anyone is thinks it
may be interesting for me to do a like a
little video recap let me know I'll do
one and I'll post it on my youtube
channel which there's a link in the
description for my channel if no one's
interested at all just don't say
anything or you could say no if you want
to be really direct about it and then I
won't make the video but it was a cool
experience so I thought I would share if
if you're interested
[Music]
so I'm just trying to figure out where I
left off right now okay
found it
John Hanson says should it be just a
functional component and then have it
brought into a container component yeah
actually to tell you the truth I haven't
looked through a lot of the components
to see if they could become functional
components and I suspect a lot of them
could I like to start out with with like
normal components and then later on I
can turn them fun it seems to be easier
although now there's a plug in a Visual
Studio code that can switch your your
components back and forth so I guess I
don't have to worry about it but it was
usually easier to switch to a functional
component instead of trying to switch
back so I I suspect you're right about
this one and about a lot of other
components in there that they could just
be functional say oh says I want to
follow along with you on these live
streams what is the schedule how do I
get into your code so the schedule is it
varies I try to stream Monday through
Friday I usually don't get all five days
and depends on when I have meetings or
what's going on so probably the best
thing to do would be subscribed to free
code camp channel and turn on
notifications on YouTube and then if you
follow me on Twitter and or Instagram I
usually post about when I'm gonna stream
I'm most consistent on Twitter
occasionally I don't have time or forget
to do it on Instagram but then at least
you'll know a little bit beforehand when
I'm gonna stream so that's if you want
to get into the code the the link to the
github repo is in the description it's
totally open source you can see
everything and then feel free to ask
questions if you need to ok Johnny
Carter says I find that component
packages are quite restrictive when
trying to match the sign specs such as
material UI have you come across any
issues yourself yeah yeah I mean we need
to a case
when I come across issues like that what
I'll do is make a I can either make a
completely new component and do all the
Styles myself which I find to be not a
great option it does give you the most
control but you end up recreating a lot
of things that you don't need to the
other option is to create a container
component around some material you eye
components and then that way you can
kind of manipulate and do what you want
with them and then the other option is
to actually manually go in to your node
modules copy and paste the code for a
particular component from the to your UI
pull it out make it your own component
adjust it enough so that it actually
works in that new component folder
that's kind of at that top level and
then you can you can change it to be
what you want the only downside to that
is material UI is gonna continue to
advance and update and your component is
not so there's a trade-off but that
gives you the maximum amount of
customized ability without having to
recreate a lot so I've done those things
that's how I do it so yeah but I found
what you give up in going with the
framework in terms of freedom to do what
you want it's it's really because you
say so much time hmm sorry you save so
much time not just in terms of building
the components themselves but in testing
you go with a well known UI framework
there are thousands of hours of tests
that have already been done by the
people to build it and by the people
that use it figuring out all the
different UI bugs that happen in
different browsers and devices and
things so that's why I generally am okay
with
you know the small annoyance of the
inflexibility that occurs sometimes
Michel Creole says might want to go to a
card template then extend it to more
specific uses yeah for sure
you know I like I kind of mentioned
before in reality we probably could just
could have used that profile card
template and adjusted it but for the
sake of the stream I thought it might
not be a bad idea to just copy it over
do our own thing and simplify it rather
than complicate an existing component so
I thought that might have been slightly
more kind of slightly easier to
understand for people who weren't that
familiar with react but that's
definitely a candidate for refactoring
see Michael Creole says is dangerously
shot in turn HTML something you made
because the name intrigues me no no it's
not what I made the the team that made
react actually made that the reason is
its title that is because you're pulling
in the raw HTML when you do that and if
you if the source is unknown or like
let's say you're allowing users to input
things and then you're displaying them
on your site that could potentially be
dangerous if if you're not checking that
data first to make sure they're not
throwing in like script tags or weird
things in there that could harm another
user so we in this case we controlled
the data and where it's coming from
so it's okay to use but you definitely
want to be sure like I mean let's say
you were building some sort of forum or
discussion board or whatever and you let
users put in data and then the data
could be displayed to other users
without any sanitization going on then
that would be that would be really bad
so that's why it's labeled dangerously
oh no John Henson said things are fuzzy
can't read a thing okay now it's fixed
all right I'm sorry about that if that
happened anyone else my stream for
whatever reason the stream occasionally
just keeps dropping off like in terms of
the like kilobits per second will just
go right down to zero and then a few
seconds later it'll pop right back up
and be it like 2500 so I don't know why
it's doing that
Nino says you've been working on this
project for a really really long time
yep yeah I have uh-huh
so I've been working on it for a long
time mainly the thing that's slowing me
down the most is just the amount of data
that needs to be brought over and the
this the quality of the data it's not in
very good shape it's not it's not
organized in a way that allows me to
just bring over a large pieces of data
in bulk and it requires a lot of cleanup
so that's what I've been working on a
lot in terms of the react stuff I really
only work on the react stuff whenever I
stream which is only you know an hour or
so a day and sometimes not every day so
it has been quite normally it would not
take nearly this long just to build a
reacts ight and in a pretty simple one
at that the data is what's really
slowing me down
so I agree this is a lot longer than
normal
Albert says how long until you finish
this project well it is supposed to
launch on June 4th
that's our date for launch I mean
potentially if it didn't launch then we
have a little bit of room you know but
should be launching around then so after
that I'll probably still work on this
and be constantly updating it but I
already have another project lined up
that'll be my main focus after this
launches Michael so earlier when I was
explaining graph QL and rest api's and
things Michael criolla Dan mentioned
rest would tell you every fruit you have
all at once and then you'd have to
search for apples and oranges yeah
actually you're right yeah there would
be potentially you just get everything
and half yeah that is a good analogy a
good piece of the analogy Stephen says
the graph QL explanation is pretty good
trying to decide if we want to dive into
it for a job you have at work okay cool
I really like it I'm definitely not as
good at getting data yet
just in terms of like the how you format
a query I was just so used to rest api's
in particular the WordPress REST API
that I could get data a lot more quickly
without having to look up how so I think
once I work more with graph QL it'll be
a lot easier for me to get data
Michael creo says you should change the
link text to would you like to know more
yeah I don't know if I want that much
text for the link I I don't want it to
wrap onto the second line when it's on a
small screen so for just for a button if
it were in a different context in a
different layout I would be okay with
that but generally I like to stick with
smaller you know one or two words for a
button
John says I actually can understand like
a second language what's happening today
all Jessie's fault ha that's good
Michael creo says I know I'm OCD but the
ordering of your import statements make
makes my eye twitch yeah my import
statements are a mess if anybody really
wants to organize an import statements
feel free if there's some plug-in that
doesn't automatically let me know cuz
I'm I'm pretty bad at that I just throw
them wherever when I'm working because
I'm just like I don't want to get
sidetracked and forget what I'm about to
do you know you know I you like you get
it all in your mind like this is what I
need to do and then if I stride they're
like okay how am I gonna organize these
I might forget where I'm at so I tried
to not let myself get distracted by the
order so it ends up a mask
Albert says I've been learning react and
redux for a year and I still don't know
how to make a website well keep at it I
mean you get you at that point I mean it
might be best
I would definitely make use of things
like create react app and next because
basically you run those and you have a
website you know it already works you
know you you have a progressive web app
that already works as is you just need
to add you know your own styles and
content and just kind of add on to it so
that's where I would say if you have in
trouble with it definitely start there
if you haven't already I I would never
do I don't want to say never but like
they'd have to be a really really good
reason for me not to use something to
build out a react app and then I just
start from already build you know set up
already configured web pack but you know
all of that
I gotta in the stream here soon so I'm
gonna try to
okay John Hanson said instead of
limiting card size fullscreen it might
be better to have a containing div that
sits in the middle and then media query
with that div will have Auto margins on
the left and right yet you know what
actually I think that's that's how I had
it set up with the styles that I brought
over so I'm thinking though it may it
may not be enough so maybe I'll just
have to increase the margins in that
case but I don't want to increase too
much it might be better to go to let's
say three columns and have it display a
little wider than to have keep two
columns but I haven't only take up just
this tiny section of the screen I think
that that may look a little weird yes
even said I don't stream cuz I make more
mistakes than you you're the king of the
bump thank you I appreciate it but I
make a lot of mistakes sometimes like
today was today maybe it was like
average amount of mistakes but um I I
don't know I try I mean I ought to be
getting good at streaming I've been
doing it for over a year now so I would
hope I'm I'm at least okay at it by now
Johnny carcasses thanks for answering I
like that you're smiling about messing
with the node package that's exactly
what I ended up doing yeah I think
normally you don't want to get in there
and mess with it but I mean it
what other sometimes that's your best
option you know so I mean I guess the
the other option be like maybe adjusted
to the way you want it's a bit of pull
request and hope that it actually makes
it into materiai or whatever framework
which I mean that's valid too but your
it's going to take longer and it's not
guaranteed so I mean maybe doing both is
the best way near ID says hi hey how's
it going and Dexter of world says what
is your visual studio code theme it's
the SETI theme so SETI iniki's got it so
SETI SETI icons and fried fire code font
there we go Fira code is that is the
font so that's why we got little things
like I'm trying to find an arrow
function I got one over here yeah so
that's why the arrow functions look like
this a little bit different and then
there's some other things that look
different too I don't really have a good
example of it right now but okay well I
gotta go gotta take my kids to soccer so
thank you all for watching really glad
it was really really glad that I had
your opinion on things and your help
with some of these things so I should be
back tomorrow I'll be streaming from the
office tomorrow maybe maybe the
afternoon not sure yet I'll let y'all
know on Twitter and Instagram when I'm
gonna stream and subscribe to this
channel and turn on your notifications
and you should get a notification as
well anyway I'll see y'all tomorrow
until then
a wonderful day